you had a bit of a twitter beef um
earlier this week with
uh coltie bra
um and i followed colton dobson yes
june 1992 lives in huntington beach
california yeah colton dobbs
cool the jets a bit but i mean like i
i've um you know i followed the both of
you you know for a while and i thought
that it was interesting watching that
unfold
um and i think this is probably a better
way to cover the topic and i've and i've
got a personal story too that i want to
share
i'll leave that towards the end because
it's around um something on this topic
of of sharpening the mind but i know
that a lot of people have come to this
for
you know their dose of red meat so let's
give them the drama and the red meat um
why don't you tell them how this how
this spat unfolded
and how it came to a conclusion right so
uh this twitter artist he's been around
for a while i think anyone who's in the
twitter space has probably seen him he
takes a take likes to take shots at
people he's been around for a while and
he had a few digs at me two or three
years ago and i largely ignored him
because i don't believe in in half
measures right i either completely
ignore somebody or i aim to destr to
destroy them
it turns out he's a cocaine addict he
gets hype in front of his computer and
he likes to start beefs for clout and
one day i had a little bit of time for
him which was three or four days ago i
had some spare time and i decided to
destroy his brand and do my absolute
best to wreck his life
and luckily he capitulated and showed
the world he was a coward before i
really managed to even get started i
mean we were only 24 hours in uh so the
real [ __ ] games didn't even start but
i think he realized that
you know there's some people on the
internet who talk and there's some
people on the internet who talk and do
something else
sorry sorry
so i missed the start so forgive me guys
but what was it that like why would he
want to pick a fight with a
champion kickboxer like where did that
come because because that's clout right
this is the thing that's amazing to me
about this whole spat when this whole
thing started everyone starts saying oh
tight coltie's gonna fight tate he was
never gonna fight me he was never going
to fight me
it's amazing to me that people were
pretending there was ever a chance even
one percent chance he was going to show
up and fight me of course not you've had
this happen a few times
sorry you've had this happen a few times
though like a few people have well it
happens all the time all the time yeah
but i mean this is the first time that
i've seen somebody that actually like
claims to be like an mma
combatant like somebody that's had
fights
listen if if two people want to fight
trust me i've been in their cage in the
ring enough times no if two people want
to fight it doesn't take long to
organize it certainly doesn't take you
know a whole bunch of talking a whole
bunch of back and forth and this guy's
talking garbage and saying he's going to
fight me and this that he's just trying
to he's trying to get status and it's
amazing to me and i actually lost a
little bit of faith in the rotting
corpse of the
masculine side of twitter as it is that
these people are sitting there
pretending there's a chance it was even
gonna happen there's people sitting
there going this is gonna be a good
fight like are you out of your mind this
guy is talking crap for clout you're
giving him attention for no reason he
doesn't deserve it he has no intention
of fighting me and i and they wait and
enough people tagged me and wasted
enough of my life reading it i thought
you know i have to dedicate 36 hours to
reckon this fool this is it's insanity
so
so the challenge came up and then
why weren't you able to follow through
to get the fight booked and then take
the deposits and set up the event like
what happened from there
so he said he'd fight me i said no
problem here's a contract and he went
silent just disappeared
because that was his intention all along
to pretend he was gonna fight and then
not sign a contract and not fight so
then i put 50 000 in escrow i was like
look you're not going to now sign a
contract and then not turn up you're not
going to waste even more of everybody's
time so i put 50 000 in escrow instantly
once again put it on twitter he started
slow replying slow replying slow
replying and at this point i understood
that he has no intention of fighting me
but he's wasted my time and he said my
name so he has to pay a price one way or
another and that's when i
took a little bit time out of my life
and instigated a campaign against his
entire family i intended on in
litigating his bloodline into eternal
poverty and i would do exactly that i
would do exactly that with a smile on my
face people don't understand right
i i'm i wouldn't say i'm bored but i
certainly miss war let's put it that way
you're gonna give me a reason if you're
gonna annoy me enough to go out of my
way i will spend 10 hours a day every
single day for the rest of my human
years inconveniencing you i will do that
and i will sit and laugh with my brother
from the seat of my private plane i
don't care if it costs me a hundred
dollars to take one from you i'll do
that trade all day and we'll see who
runs out of money first i'm that guy so
when he decided to finally keep saying
my name to the point where i was like
okay we're gonna fight then i realized
it was all just a lie he's not even
gonna give me the honor he's not gonna
give he doesn't have enough honor as a
man to turn up i want the glory i want
to smash his face in he ain't gonna give
me the chance well then i have to ruin
his life don't i what else am i supposed
to do so i i began a campaign
what was the um what was the initial
beef with you like you just he just
started running his mouth about how you
weren't what you said you were or like
where did it come from
yeah i think the lowest and easiest you
probably because i mean it was
convenient that it got tight around the
time that that that you started posting
about the bugatti and it ended up on the
bugatti website with your
uh name embroidered on the headrest
yeah i think you you'll know this as
well yourself the easiest way to try and
cloud chase is to find somebody of high
status and attack them right that's all
it is i mean you you probably get this
yourself right if you're a nobody and
you want some clout you find somebody of
high status and you run your mouth
so i mean i'm out there he just i guess
he just decided me i don't know why he'd
pick me
i actually like to think that
i
i'm not gonna i mean nobody's scared of
anybody on twitter or the internet right
but i like to think that there's enough
about me he should have known what was
gonna happen
he should have known i was going to do
something about it i don't know why he
was he's ignorant drunk high stupid
autistic not sure which one he is
probably a combination of them all
but he just wants some clout right and
in general i don't have that many haters
online i don't have that many so i guess
he thought he'd be unique and be the one
who wants to run his mouth to me look
like a tough guy you do get hate though
like i noticed a lot of the exchanges
back and forth there's a lot of people
that that
i don't know what kind of language they
think that is necessary to use but they
certainly
pick their
favorite guy right like everybody's got
their favorite fighter you know if
there's a fight like you know there's
you know like there's people that are
gonna side with tate there's people are
gonna side with his opponent sort of
thing right and
you know they get in
you know they get into the uh
the emotion the energy like the whole
you know scenario of the whole thing and
then it just kind of collapses on itself
and implodes but now
the part that i wanted to get to was um
how winners win right because i mean
you've been up against this i'm sure
your entire life i mean you're a guy
that came from no one you started
kickboxing uh i've seen your record
we've talked before you're clearly who
who you say you are
um
you know there's a first like initial
moment when i came across you know
andrew tate on twitter and i was like
who is this guy he's you know he's loud
he's boisterous he's very confident
you know these are really full of [ __ ]
or he really is who he says you know he
is and it took me a while to figure it
out right and obviously you know i've
you know i've made my conclusion on that
but um you know then you went like full
full on on on him like you're talking
about you know you've got his family
involved i think you mentioned
absolutely name
well i've certainly got his family
all of them all of them
scum richard they will pay you know
how did you manage to include his family
in a lawsuit like like how would they be
involved with him running his mouth on
twitter that's the part that i'm trying
to connect the dots on they birth scum
and they will pay the price
listen here's the thing about winning in
life there's no such thing as rambo
everyone has this idea of this lone cat
rambo kind of thing the most dangerous
people in the world are people with
networks they're people who know people
and and it's people with liquid wealth
listen i'm part of networks and groups
i'm part of organizations where i can
drop a 20 000 prize and say
this twitter tag 20 grand with ideas and
information that's going to destroy his
life it took that's all i did it took
three minutes i had his name his address
his dad's job his sister's bra size you
name it i had all of it it was done it
took three minutes
that many people sold them out eh
oh abs everybody look no there's no such
thing as anonymity that's the thing i
don't understand with the internet you
put your face you put your face out
there i put my face out there a lot of
guys i put my real face my real name out
there like we're one of the few that
actually do that here
exactly and people are out there trying
to hide but you can't even hide you
can't hide in this world it took all of
three minutes to get all the information
and as for litigating his parents listen
i don't i'll say this right here right
now and i don't care because i might
still litigate them and i'll still say
this i don't need a reason
you're gonna have to defend yourself
regardless that's the thing about the
american legal system you cannot ignore
it i don't care if it costs me a million
dollars to take a thousand dollars out
of your bank you're gonna be in court
twice a month for the rest of your human
years i don't care i will sue you for
any and every reason forever and you're
gonna have to hire lawyers and turn up
forever i'll do that i'm that guy i'm
petty i'm petty and i've got a lot of
money in a lot of time so it's not even
about guilty it's not about why it's
just about because i can it's one of
many many things i was gonna do i'd buy
the property next to his father's airbnb
and list it for free i will bankrupt you
you don't understand the levels i will
go to i'm that guy and the guy and he
was as soon as he could feel it and he
felt it because people turned up at his
door once i had his address i started
putting i didn't want to get banned from
twitter obviously it happened in the end
anyway but at first i put his street
name then i put his house number and
then and and then when guys turned up at
his house i listen i had to fly some
friends of mine from vegas to l.a like i
had to spend money on this [ __ ] this
took time out of my life when he looked
out the window and saw the suv then he
starts apologizing on the internet like
oh [ __ ] welcome to the real world
worlds have consequences and it wasn't
even hard for me to do richard all i did
was i sent some messages to a few
private groups i'm in and said look cash
prize this guy needs to pay that's all
it was it wasn't even difficult and i
still haven't even decided i still might
do it richard you know what i still
might do it i still might litigate him
into the [ __ ] ground why not what
else i got to do
i don't like him
yeah um no i don't like it i told him
this you've been warned internet
listen i'm a man i'm a man of honor
right if i have a problem with anybody
and they agree to fight me and they turn
up and they beat me i'll take the l i'm
not petty i'm not i can't i'm not all
those guys who can't take the hell if he
would have gotten the cage and won i'd
take it if he would have gotten the cage
and lost i still would have dropped it
but if you're gonna say my name and
pretend you're gonna fight me and then
just waste everybody's time waste the
fight promoters time waste a bunch of
idiots on twitter's time everyone
pretended this is going to be a thing no
he deserves to pay he deserves to pay
because words have consequences before
the internet if he was talking like he
was talking to my face he would have had
serious facial injuries
siri and he knows that yeah so
you know what what's that what's that
mike tyson no no no richard he has to
pay
i might have to do it
you